from the beach to the court pickleball
is becoming more popular courts are
popping up all across the valley and one
local man is using the sport to get back
in shape yeah Mary Jane beliesza joining
us live this morning with his story and
Mary Jane here's the thing John and I
haven't played pickleball but we're so
excited about this and kind of I mean
not only is it fun but I mean it's a
good way to get in shape huh
no you know John Heather absolutely I
mean I have gotten a few rounds in just
before uh our six o'clock hour here just
so I could also prep myself and the
really cool part is this is really
accessible to the community there's a
lot of Courts actually for free in many
areas across the valley including
Henderson Summerlin and of course miles
Reynolds he's been getting up and early
and playing for us too he's going to be
joining me here right now miles I'm
going to have to ask you to step aside
here he is the owner of sport court in
the Las Vegas Valley and Miles we've
been talking about this all morning long
just how easy and accessible it is for
the community you've been growing your
business by pretty much building all
these courts across Las Vegas tell me
where can people go if they want to play
uh the easiest place to find out what's
close to you is uh pickleball has a
nationwide website that's usapa
pickleball and you put in your zip code
and it'll show you what courts are close
to you how many courts there are you
know when when the times are best to
play so that's the best resource as far
as what's close to you and then even
just going on the city's website they
have a lot of leagues for kids adults
and really all ages and
almost two is that you
in summer when people are trying to get
out and about but still find a way to
have a good time while enjoying it for
free and so where have you been kind of
building all of these courts around the
valley you know it's a mix because we do
both commercial and residential so what
we see happening is a lot of new
construction both uh you know in the
backyard or a lot of these communities
are taking these older tennis courts
that aren't being used as much in
converting them to pickleball well
that's awesome and of course I know that
we were talking about in the last half
hour that I'm going to take a shot here
I mean we've been having a little bit of
fun so now it's my turn to get on the
court and hopefully I can get a good uh
shot because this is my first time right
yeah
all right
there it is nice nice forehand
Folly Mary Jane's got it you know
wimbledon's underwear
wimbledon's happening now I feel like
she's going for the line next thing we
know she's going to be in the neighbor's
house but did you see a pickleball
Norcross and get the dogs barking at you
they're like again
many times Mary Jane okay good job it is
becoming more popular to be sure I gotta
get on this gotta do it we had the big
uh Clark County had a big tournament a
pickleball tournament I want to say it
was at Sunset Park I think and they had
some courts down there uh commissioner
Gibson down there and it was a big big
deal okay and then up The Plaza Hotel
they have the roof of the plaza yeah so
it's it's getting really we got to get
into it